George Santos
George Santos the Republican congressman
who claimed to be Jewish though
his defense was he never claimed to be
Jewish he claimed to be Catholic but he
said he had Jewish ancestry which meant
he was Jewish which is a funny line
people are pretending to be offended by
it but it's a very very funny line and
if it were just that you might say okay
he said he had a Jewish great grandpa or
something somewhere maybe maybe he did
maybe that's in the family tree maybe
there was a Jewish Milkman walking
around Brazil or wherever the Santos are
from I don't know whatever maybe it
could be but then more lies kept coming
up he lied about his education he said
that he went to NYU he said he said he
went to Baruch College he said he went
to Horace Mann before College none of
that seems to be true he said he works
for Goldman Sachs that doesn't seem to
be true
he he said he's a gay guy but until two
weeks before his first congressional run
in 2020 he was married
to a woman so now we don't believe this
guy and there's pressure on Kevin
McCarthy
to boot him out of Congress
Kevin McCarthy now Speaker of the House
says
he will continue to serve
George Santos says I'm not resigning and
Kevin McCarthy says I'm not going to
make him resign
and why how does Kevin McCarthy justify
keeping George Santos in the House of
Representatives
he told reporters yeah okay he's lied
so have a lot of people here in the
Senate and others
Now Kevin McCarthy he's not the leader
in the Senate George Santos is not the
Senate why does he say that he is
obviously referring to Elizabeth Warren
yeah George Santos seems to have made up
a ton of stuff about his biography
because he claims to be a Native
American
has he Advanced his career by being the
whitest woman to ever walk the earth and
pretending to be
Pocahontas no I don't think so
has he did he lie about his academic
record yeah oh I guess he can be
president now Okay Kevin McCarthy said
hold on the bar
the bar now to be kicked out of Congress
as you embellish your back you lie about
your background you embellish your
resume okay I guess we got to kick out
everybody in Congress then and
specifically the Democrats who have done
this brazenly in recent years and I
gotta say I totally agree with Kevin
McCarthy here I wouldn't trust George
Santos for anything I wouldn't trust him
to get me a cup of coffee but I wouldn't
tell him to resign we've got a razor
thin House Majority right now and the
Democrats never resign when they get
caught in these embarrassments tell you
what we'll make a deal once Elizabeth
Warren resigns for pretending to be
Sitting Bull then George Santos can
resign for lying about all of his
background
okay and then if that doesn't happen
then Congressman Santos I hope you do a
great job voting for good conservative
principles and allowing the Republicans
to keep their majority only 16 percent
of Jen Sears love America this according
to a new morning consult survey released
this week shows that when asked about
how they view living in their country
gen Z adults had extremely low opinions
of the United States well 52 percent of
all U.S adults said they were proud to
live in America only 16 percent of gen Z
agreed compare this with the Boomers
almost three out of every four Boomers
say that they love America proud to live
in America uh more than half of gen xers
54 percent say they love America even
the Millennials who basically hate
America say that they're proud of their
country love their country and then just
one in six
less than one and six Zoomers say that
they love their country I am not
surprised at all
not merely because the youths these days
those youths they don't know how good
they got it when I was a kid you know I
trudged uphill both ways in the snow and
the sleet and the fire and the brimstone
these kids they're so soft they don't
it's not just that
the reason that I'm not surprised at all
that gen Z doesn't love
their country is that nobody is really
defending the country as a country we
know that the libs hate America we know
that the libs say that America is an
evil racist sexist this is thatist
phobic place that's always been
oppressive and terrible to all sorts of
people and we've got to topple the
statues of our forebearers and we should
shred the Constitution and we should
start over because of how terrible this
place is so there you go right off
basically half of gen Z right there
that's the way that the libs are
educated today that wasn't exactly true
for the Boomers the Boomers became
disaffected with America and
disillusioned but they weren't educated
that way they were educated to love
their country and then
you're seeing declining national love
and national pride after that but okay
write off at least half of the Zoomers
all those lives
even the conservatives I think
are educated today not to love their
country
I think that over the last 30 40 years
the way that even the young
conservatives have been raised is to
think not what can I do for my country
but what can my country do for me
they've been raised to believe that at
the heart of politics is the individual
that's what politics is really about and
the government the nation such as it is
only exists so that I can get more stuff
the whole point of the government the
reason those founding fathers and
framers of the Constitution went through
all that trouble was just to set up a
system where the government doesn't mean
anything and the nation has no unified
purpose and there's no such thing as the
common good that's commie talk if you
ask me and the whole reason the thing
exists is just to get people to leave me
alone and get off my lawn and let me
keep my money that's what government's
for that's what the the polity
representing the whole nation is for
just about me getting more stuff
I'm barely exaggerating
so okay you got the lips naturally hate
their country and they want to erase the
borders and erase any sense of natural
inheritance or identity
but you got the conservatives basically
neglecting national identity
and being raised in a fanatically small
government borderline anarchistic kind
of uh ideology that even if it is not
put in practice does go into the minds
of the young people who have been raised
in it
and so ideas like the common good ideas
like a shared National purpose ideas
like the Republic Republicans from race
publica stuff we hold in common things
we have in common the ideas like the
sumumbonum this was an idea that before
the enlightenment before the modern live
philosophers came around people
understood that that politics has
existed in part at least to pursue good
and avoid evil that was what it was
about and then after the enlightenment
you have this big shift to a view of the
polity as just a a big social contract
where the main thing that the government
is supposed to do is get everyone to
leave everybody else alone and we have
no shared pursuit of the common good we
can't even really identify what the
common good is all we can identify is
the common bad this is what Thomas Hobbs
writes about in Leviathan and you see
shades of this throughout all of the
liberal writers who come afterward we
don't who knows what's good you know
what you say is good maybe I don't think
is good but we do know what's bad and
what's bad is when you take my property
and so as a result of that we've got to
just have a government that protects
certain
basically material rights and then all
that virtue stuff that goes out the
window okay well if you're going to
throw all that virtue stuff out the
window people aren't going to love their
country
if you're going to throw out the notion
that there is anything lovable about the
country as a country
then people aren't going to love it it's
not the zoomer's fault I hate to defend
the Zoomers but it's not their fault
become a member today use code
knowlescana w l e s at checkout for two
months free on a all access plan any
daily wire plan you want dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout
[Music]
foreign
[Music]